thank you
good evening ladies and gentlemen thank
you very much for being here it is my
pleasure to introduce Secretary of
Defense Lori Austin III and chairman of
the Joint Chiefs
when she's a staff General Mark milley
the secretary and the chairman will
provide some brief opening remarks and
then we'll have a few minutes to take
some questions I will moderate those
questions and call on the reporters and
I would ask you to limit your follow-up
since we do have a limited amount of
time today
I appreciate your assistance for this Mr
secretary over to you sir thanks Brad
well good afternoon everyone
we've made excellent progress at our
sixth meeting of the Ukraine defense
contact group
and we were joined by my good friend
Alexi reznikov Ukraine's minister of
defense
and by Major General most Calia
Ukraine's Joint Forces command
I'm very grateful to them for joining us
and for their heroic leadership
they updated the contact group on the
latest battlefield Dynamics
on Ukraine's priority needs
and on Ukraine's requirements to defend
itself for the Long Haul
I'm also very pleased that ministers and
Chiefs of Defense from some 50 countries
took part in today's discussion
then again underscores the resolve of
the International Community
to support Ukraine's self-defense
after Russia's crew and unprovoked
invasion
and that resolve has only been
heightened by the deliberate cruelty
of Russia's new barrage against Ukraine
6.
those assaults on targets with no
military purpose
again revealed mamales of Putin's war of
choice
but Russia's atrocities have further
United the nations of Goodwill that
stand with you Frank
so we are here because rules matter
because rights matter
and because sovereignty matters
and in the past few days Putin has given
us all
another grand preview of a future
in which the appetites of aggressive
autocrats outweigh the rights of
peaceful States
we would all be less secure
in a world where big powers can assault
their peaceful neighbors and trample
their borders by force
and the free citizens of Ukraine have an
inalienable right
to govern themselves
and to choose their own future
they underpin
oh these are Bedrock principles and they
underpin the rules-based international
order that makes us all more secure
this contact group will stay true to
those values
regardless of the outcome of any
individual battle
and we will not waver in our support for
UK Ukraine's right to defend itself
from Russia's Imperial ambitions
Ukraine's forces have used systems like
high Mars to change the Dynamics of the
war that Putin started
and that's helped Ukrainian forces
seize the initiative during their
counter-offensive
so we'll continue to rush in the
capabilities to help Ukraine in the
current fight
can I come in the contact group members
who have moved Heaven and Earth
to get weapons and equipment into the
hand of the Ukrainian forces
at the same time our allies and partners
are driving hard
to sustain Ukraine's Defenders for the
Long Haul
as a conflict has evolved
the mission of this contact group has
evolved as well
so today the contact group underscored
our shared commitment to keep on
supplying Ukraine's Defenders with the
capability that they will need in the
difficult weeks months and years ahead
we discuss ways to
do even more to train Ukrainian forces
who are making such impressive use of
their new capabilities
and we pushed to Galvanize our
industrial basis
to fire up production for assistance to
defend Ukraine
even while meeting our own security
needs
the leaders here are built on the
important progress from the September
28th meeting
of our national armaments directors
under the auspices of this contact group
Denmark and the UK shared updates on
several Copenhagen conference
initiatives
including the UK's International donors
fund for pulling International funding
for critical capabilities
and as we increase our long-term support
for Ukraine
transparency and accountability remain
crucial
at today's meeting we discuss the
accountability measures Ukraine is using
to ensure that advanced weapons are
fully tracked
we also discuss ways to work together to
build on our momentum
and to meet new challenges
we know that Ukraine still needs even
more long-range fires
and air defense systems and artillery
systems
along with other crucial capabilities
and I'm grateful to our many allies and
partners who have race to meet Ukraine's
self-defense needs
often pulling from their own stocks or
purchasing capabilities from domestic
industry
let me especially commend Germany for
its recent delivery of an Irish T air
defense system
this critical donation will help Ukraine
better defend its civilians from Russian
airstrikes
and Germany also recently announced that
it would deliver more Mars rocket
systems and houses
and all that shows long-term support for
Ukraine's Defenders
I want to also recognized several
countries doing especially important
work together to ramp up production on
Key Systems and reinvigorate their
industrial basis
and so Norway Germany and Denmark have
all invested in Slovakia as homegrown
production of power juice
and that just shows how much we can do
when we come together in common purpose
these initiatives and many more will
help us build momentum and ensure that
the future Ukrainian armed forces are
capable
and
have the ability to sustain themselves
now some countries aren't in a position
to offer lethal assistance
but we urge them to provide vital
non-legal Aid such as medical supplies
and cold weather gear that the
ukrainians need to fight in the winter
because every contribution counts
and the members of this contact group
Stand United in our support for Ukraine
self-defense
through any season
We Stand United
by our commitment to the rules-based
international order that underpins
Global Security
we stay United against the deliberate
use of war and atrocity to
seize territory redraw borders and
trample The Sovereign rights of peaceful
States
and as President Biden has said We Stand
United against the global politics of
fear coercion and Conquest
thank you and I'll turn it over to
General milley for his opening comments
Mr Austin uh thank you for your
steadfast leadership this contact group
I would not even be in existence without
the leadership of secretary Austin and I
also uh want to thank Ukrainian minister
of defense and especially also who's not
here uh General zaluzny my counterpart
in Ukraine for leading the Ukrainian
military in their efforts for their
freedom I maintain contact with him two
to three times a week General cavoli
even more than that and of course our
staffs are in contact on a day-to-day
basis I also want to thank all the
ministers and the chiefs of defense that
were here at this meeting today
representing 50 countries that's an
incredible statement of resolve and
international support for the freedom of
Ukraine and I am confident that this
group will stay together for as long as
it takes today as secretary pointed out
this group met for this sixth time with
senior representatives from each of
these countries and it's a testament to
our condemnation Collective condemnation
the international condemnation of the
illegal invasion of Ukraine by Russia
this fight is not just in Ukraine's
interest
it is in the global interest to protect
as the secretary pointed out the
rules-based international order and that
is our purpose that has been given to us
the uniform military from our civilian
leadership which is to uphold the
rules-based international order that was
established some 80 years ago at the
conclusion of World War II
and our end state is equally clear
it is to ensure that Ukraine remains a
free independent Sovereign Nation
and the ways and means
that we are doing that is through
security Force assistance with lethal
and non-lethal Aid in order to enable
Ukraine to fight for themselves
Ukraine is not asking for soldiers from
any other countries
the ukrainians are willing to fight for
themselves all they ask for is the means
to do it and as President Biden has said
in many other national leaders have said
we will do as much as we can for as long
as we can and we will do as much as it
takes for as long as it takes
this contact group remains critical
to the mission of supplying Ukraine with
the capabilities
they need to fight for their country
and this war is a war of choice a war of
Choice by Russia
and Russia is paying an extremely high
cost
a high cost in human life and casualties
and weapons material
and in their economy each day
that this war goes on
costs Russia more and more and the
Russian people begin to suffer
Russia has chosen in response to
escalate
with a recent mobilization of three
hundred thousand call-ups for constraint
for conscripts
they have tried to conduct an illegal
annexation of four of the oblas in
occupied Ukraine
they have increased their rhetoric
to include rhetoric about nuclear
weapons
and of course in the past few days
Russia has increased their strikes on
civilian infrastructure power generation
and dams
Russia has deliberately struck civilian
infrastructure with the purpose of
harming civilians
they have targeted the elderly the women
and the children of Ukraine
indiscriminate and deliberate attacks
on civilians targets is a war crime in
the international rules of War
Ukraine and its citizens have suffered
greatly
but the people in the nation of Ukraine
endure and they are an inspiration to
all
the Nations gathered here today are
committed
to the assisting
Ukraine defend itself
Ukraine continues to fight with bravery
and honor and the Ukraine military is
making continued progress as you see in
their counteroffensives in the donaste
car keysan luhansk and elsewhere
Ukrainian military has fought
extraordinarily well
and the discussions at this contact
group today
were about meeting Ukraine's current
needs and also supporting them in the
Long Haul
we focused on air defense on Canon
artillery rocket artillery maneuver
tanks infantry fighting Vehicles armed
personnel carriers also discuss training
in a wide variety of non-lethal support
these systems the associated ammunition
are critical
for Ukraine to continue the fight
and they are employing these weapons
extremely well
so I'll stop there and I thank you and
welcome your questions Mr secretary
chairman thank you very much our first
question will go to John this may New
York Times
today you said quote our resolve to
support Ukraine's Defenders extends
through all seasons unquote with winter
fast approaching do you expect them to
do you expect the Ukrainian Armed Forces
to continue fighting to retake their
territory throughout the season until
spring
thanks John uh the battlefield remains
dynamic and uh winner always presents a
challenge when it comes to fighting but
the the International Community remains
United and focused uh and and committed
to doing everything that we can to help
Ukraine
protect his interest
and defended Sovereign territory
I expect that Ukraine will continue to
do everything it can throughout the
winter to uh to regain its uh its
territory and to uh and to be effective
on the battlefield and we're going to do
everything we can to make sure that they
have what what's required to be
effective and uh most recently we've
seen them be very effective both in the
East and down in the South as they've
taken back uh quite a bit of territory
from the Russians so we can expect that
that type of activity will continue on
through the winter
Deborah Haynes Sky News
thanks very much
um a British spy Chief this week said
that Russia is one running out of
weapons
How concerned are you though about
Western stockpiles and whether Western
weapons could run out first and
specifically on air defense systems
given the need from Ukraine why are
Western allies not sending these systems
in Faster is it because of a lack of
political will or a lack of supplies
well certainly is not a question of lack
of will
the commitment the resolve that the
chairman and I witnessed uh in this
contact group feeding today
was inspiring and that's what I told the
members of the group
they they remain committed to doing
everything they can to generate
additional capabilities and you heard me
say at the top that several countries
have are working together to expand
capacity in their industrial base and I
think it's that kind of initiative that
kind of activity that will create other
opportunities for us as we go forward we
we talked about air defense the
requirement for additional air defense
capabilities and countries I have every
confidence that countries will do
whatever they can if they can to
generate additional capabilities you've
heard us talk about providing nay Sands
and uh and that's kind of that's good
capability is going to gonna really help
the ukrainians you heard heard me say
earlier that Germany is providing an rst
system and again we I expect to see more
capability come forward we saw some
additional countries volunteer to
provide Munitions for those naysam
systems today and that that's always
encouraging refreshing so uh the the
will is certainly there to uh to do
everything we can for as long as we can
in the commitment again was inspiring
it's good to uh
agency Fox press
secretary after a President Putin's
threat about the nuclear use of nuclear
weapons you said repeatedly that you
have seen nothing that could cause you
to change your nuclear posture will you
communicate when you when this posture
changes and uh chairman I have a
question for you too
um we spoke about air defense as a
priority and the Nations and the German
aristi that have to be ordered to the
industry
um but it's urgent so in the meantime
are there other systems maybe order
systems that the allies of Ukraine could
could find faster
so
um let me Begin by saying Shelby that
Putin Sable rallying is reckless nuclear
Sable rattling is reckless and
irresponsible we don't expect to to see
and hear that kind of behavior from a
major nuclear power and so that's very
dangerous and you've heard a number of
leaders around the world emphasize that
you should know and I know you do that
we take this very seriously and this is
something that we remain focused on and
we continue to watch indicators
indications and any type of warning that
uh that he may have made a decision to
go in a different direction we've not
seen any indicators at this point that
would lead us to believe that but again
it's not something we look at once and
leave alone this is something we remain
focused on 24 hours a day seven days a
week
so so we um put it in context a little
bit
what Ukraine is asking for and and what
uh we think can be provided is an
integrated air missile defense system so
that doesn't control all the air space
over Ukraine but they're designed to
control priority targets that Ukraine
needs to protect and what you're looking
at really is short range low altitude
systems and then medium range medium
altitude and then long range and high
altitude systems and it's a mix of all
of these that deny the airspace to
Russian aircraft fixed Wing or rotary
aircraft and Russian missile defense
right so that's what you're trying to
create you're trying to create a
defensive system so far Ukraine is very
effectively used their sa-6s and eights
uh s300s and STD 10 11s Etc so they've
been very effective at denying Russian
air superiority and that in turn has
denied the Russians the ability to
conduct ground combined arms maneuver so
what what needs to be done here by all
of the various countries that were at
the conference today is chip in and help
them
rebuild and and sustain an integrated
air and missile defense system
specifically older systems like you were
just asking about Ukraine has asked for
hawk or improved talk ihoc as it's
called that's a medium altitude medium
range system it's an older system but
it's quite effective and and there's
other systems out there throughout you
know throughout the world that are
available many countries have Patriot
many countries have other systems
there's a whole series of Israeli
systems that are quite capable the
Germans have systems as we mentioned so
a lot of the countries that were here
today have a wide variety of systems uh
and and the the task will be to bring
those together get them deployed get
them trained because each of these
systems is different make sure that they
can link together with a command and
control the communication systems and
make sure they have Radars that and talk
to each other so they can acquire
Targets on the inbound flights so it's
it's quite complicated from a technical
standpoint it is achievable and that's
what we're aiming at
okay it'll take a little bit
thank you sir the final question we'll
go to the Vladimir ruinets from ictv
thank you for this opportunity uh I'm
one of those who this Monday just this
Monday wasn't sure that I would be able
to be here because of the airstrikes
that we experienced in Kiev and the the
question I'm going to ask is not mine is
the is the people people of Ukraine
would like to ask you when will they be
able to just sleep well and not be
afraid to leave their families behind
and go on a trip like this because I'm
really I'm here and I'm really
anxious about what is happening to my
family back home so when are the systems
going to be provided and is there a
possibility that the sky is going to be
safe
uh the short answer to your question sir
is the systems will be provided as fast
as we can physically get them there and
this is something as I said at the top
that we remain focused on uh and uh
we're going to provide
systems uh that that we have available
that countries like Germany has
available we're also going to try to
provide additional Munitions to the
existing systems that the that the
Ukrainian forces are using as long as
there's a conflict goes on there will
always be uncertainty so it's very
difficult to predict when it's exactly
when it's going to be safe to to move
about move in and out of the country and
I know that you're concerned about your
family uh and and you and you certainly
that's that's understandable but we're
going to do everything we can as fast as
we can to help the Ukrainian forces get
the capability they need to protect the
Ukrainian people that's very very
important to us and and by the way it
was important to all the 50 members that
were on that were in that meeting today
and their Chiefs of Defense uh and this
is uh I mean the utility of this
Ukraine defense contact group I just
can't
I can't over emphasize how useful this
is because it helps us to address
current near-term problems and mobilize
resources much faster than we otherwise
would be able to and again I don't want
to over I don't want to exaggerate this
point but I have to tell you that I I
remain impressed by the commitment of
the of the members of the group and for
the most part these are ministers of
defense that show up to every meeting
and not uh not surrogates
worry about Africans
story
I'm afraid that's all the time that we
have available for today Mr secretary
chairman thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen
this concludes our president
next week
foreign